prima tutti ragazzi benvenuti a me sono
video sono fa vj sono ci siamo trovati
sul nostro ipad è il mio dispositivo
incredibile rivoluzionario per far
partire delle cose chiamate applicazioni
nel 2015 nuova impostazione dell'ipad
che permette di fare una cosa
rivoluzionaria che quando voi prendete
il vostro dispositivo da così e poi fate
così lui gira sentimi siri ma è un caso
che io abbia scritto 69 sulla
percentuale della batteria
dì la verità che sei una sporcaccione io
insisto
io non lo so che sei tu che insisti
perché mi guardi con questi occhi che mi
vorresti portare a letto
a tutto ciò che mi serve sulla nuvola
sulla nuvola ragazzo segò koupéla dai la
patata rifare la intro perché ancora non
siamo partiti per niente lo sarò questa
roba mi faccia l'area ogni volta un
gesto è da tutti i ragazzi e femmine di
questo video sono barge e oggi siamo su
porca [ __ ] ho sbagliato
e oggi siamo sudan john hight five o
scaricato questo ragazzi che è gratuito
ma sono talmente bravo a questi
videogame che sono riuscito ad uscire
durante il caricamento è partito un
filmato a caso mio dio mio dio che io mi
avessi di dei cinema che trovi roba più
bello per chi non lo sapesse questo
videogame dove ci si mena ma
prepotentemente e siccome io sono una
donna
credetemi sono davvero una donna ho
deciso di chiamarmi da buona donna mi
sono chiamato pippo una chiave
un'occhiata alla mappa chiamandosi ho
fatto il tutorial rega perché avevo
portato imporanti verrà sparso molto
sangue in città ed è certo zio state pro
subire la tirannia di pippo il
conquistatore vogliono pescatori amo il
ladro i nomi mistress and keys pippo non
sarà un problema
che bello sorella celestina anche non è
una sua ipo ti sento 26 la cestista
usando la via dei sogni per parlarti da
lontano è una scuola telepatica oppure
c'è semplicemente lo smartphone che
cazzo
a casa la partita moustaki che si parmi
vomita addosso come tifar madonna mi ha
lanciato una sfera del drago credo che
lui stia usando un nuovo rasoio gillette
2000 lame nomadi mi esattamente come
stai usando congregazione essere un
calciatore mi fa non voler venire una
cagata incredibile ma dovrei essere
quello che pavimento ho scelto le due
spade che smanettano di brutto io non la
voglio gillet lurido bilanciare le lame
hamas i stronzo
accidenti laggiù oddio a quello lì manca
un braccio ecco ci hanno detto di quei
tizi che cosa sta facendo
non ci sono più gli uomini di una volta
e se non li faccio io fuori non li fa
fuori nessuno gas e degli smidollati di
merda nave è jean pertanto quando
continuamente accerchiato da gente ma
continua a fare i culi manco fossi inu
yasha sta arrivando una di quelle
mazzate che ti ricordi per tutta la vita
che tanto stai morendo cui preparare
domani in nome di tron tv distruggerò
ciao schleck che ha e vedi che verde ti
sei ingoiato una persona frate ma poi
guarda che se c'è stata una sola testa
mica sei più trasgressiva e senti minuti
mi muori per cortesia grazie seri
compiuto ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta è
stata la roma ho trovato una spada da
infilarmi nel ca pranzo e molto barbone
ma come pechino cdo rec che non sei una
bestemmia un nome di è stato sera sera
kiss kiss e ragazzi dobbiamo trovare
questa shiran perché credo sia una
parente di eder sheeran
per pippo eccolo che arriva pippo si
erano fermati tra zio ama questo 1
online io mi chiamo before
ciao zio mi chiamo b può piacere
dispiace zio ma solo nel periodo nel
quale ho le mie cose e picchio che la
metà basta libera amica che gentildonna
che sono ragazzi
in cosa più bella che abbia mai visto in
tutta la mia vita
[Musica]
ragazzi ma da questo tizio che devo
uccidere che non ho ancora capitato
questa la macelleria mida duetti di
formaggio per cortesia e va bene sono
comparsi dal nulla
che cosa sei che cazzo stiamo facendo
scappa lui adesso che cosa scappi a
gaione a secco a prima non si era
accorto che devo posto secondo te senti
marchi blue hawaii una sfera del drive
da regalo perfetto fulmine di pegaso
mirati merda non ho capito dove sta
andando su disco
ecco l'ho trovata a [ __ ] aree di caccia
i capelli rossi po come il cirano se
come questo apparente ve lo dico
facciamo così canta we think in out loud
vediamo se sei in grado di immortale
guardiano questa non è think in out loud
di sicuro che con figli guardiani
immortali cos'è un beyblade
come faccio a sconfiggere dagli
immortali impossibile sono immortali
come li uccido infatti non muore nessuno
ragazzi sono invincibili tutti che devo
fare adoces cassare prima lo scettro
scommetto che vai vai picchia picchia
piquet al mio compagno è quasi morto
perché un decelebrato prova beffa i
ragazzi mi sembra di aver giocato contro
un bel i due bei place sono pippo
dannazione è scappata tra tranquilla
pippo adesso la prendiamo ci abbiam fa
targhetta tratto il mio compagni è morto
cioè non c'è più vita e noi come fa
stare in piedi e la stessa vitalità che
ho io la mattina prima di andare a
scuola giorno trovato in big money se io
ti mostrassi il migù dei che cosa ne
pensere stima va bene ok ma che fai te
che cazzo è successo no ma che cazzo
vuoi
no non volevo non volevo farla utente
innanzitutto gode lo dici a tua mamma
perché secondo me a just fish just fish
ci manca solo che io giochi con uno che
si chiama just pesce già allora ragazzi
unioni fra st missione così sembra la
mia scuola questa è la madonna e cos'è
che figlio
mica sono entrati tipo in pirati dei
caraibi che sto cazzo pal quando
un'altra tizia rai andare a parlare con
ciao fish
beh ma perché io sono io o la patata
quindi io faccio un cazzo e lui lavora
lei ragazzi non dio spaccato un barile
di mele a caso è scusa non volevo
spaccarti bari e di me
new york solofra delle mele strategy
compravo ok
l'utile che aprì le gambe non sei più
[ __ ] di pippo al giorno d'oggi non
si può parlare con le persone
asta del rampicante però ad un'asta la
mettiamo all'asta non faceva ridere
manco per il pene
ma quante botte che torna donna e io
devo andare di qua eccolo sopravvivi
all'incontro con i banditi questi sono
banditi senti zia tanto ci pensa code
fish a farti fuori non ti preoccupare
non è che ci siano troppi nemici e che
me ne fotte tutti è questa la stronza
bandito l'ha ma non è morta
ho vinto io mai così big money forza ho
vinto io
io ormai le missioni e finisco così e
senza figli mia richiesta l'alleanza no
perché giustina negli amici non la
voglio semmai giustino lilo nel cane
fonema giustina 9 lei e possono chiudere
qui ragazzi se qualcuno vuole provare a
battere sheeran fatelo voi perché ci
metterà un cimento navi taglio sono
scarso va bene quello si è capito tanto
il gioco lo potete scaricare sia che
avete iphone che che android che windows
phone però se batte sheeran voglio
mandate uno screen perché voglio dire se
canta sera siete prestiti scrivere ci
vediamo nel prossimo video è la ragazza
non so chi sia il tuo ragazzo a dire il
vero non so nemmeno che sia tu puoi
dirmi o questo a minchia di ipad in mano
da due ore non hai capito chi sono sono
fa vj favi j tutto attaccato fa vj tutto
attaccato fa vj tutto attaccato
ma va ai ragazzi la chiudo qui perché
sennò finiamo più spero che vi sia
piaciuto fare un episodio solo sussidi
comunque prima o poi fatemi sapere se
siete più prodi me ma probabilmente lo
sarete a dungeon hunter se io concludo
quell'episodio cose seguito da ragazzi